Du siehst jetzt deine Schablone und da ist eine
Mittellinie, die stellt die Körpermitte dar.
Also wie in der Schnittkonstruktion von einem Kleidungsstück
ist das jetzt die Körpermitte und auf der werden wir auch
anfangen zu zeichnen.
In Adobe Illustrator werden wir zunächst erstmal nur ein
Teil von dem Kleidungsstück zeichnen,
also auch wieder ganz ähnlich wie in der
Schnittkonstruktion.
Wir machen erst eine Hälfte von dem Rock,
dann werden wir dieses Teil kopieren und spiegeln und dann
zu einem Rock zusammensetzen.
Das dient dazu,
dass dann die Symmetrie wirklich perfekt ist.
Du gehst also jetzt in Höhe der Teile auf die
Körpermitte und setzt dort deinen ersten Punkt mit der
Zeichenfeder.
Dann gehst du auch wieder in Höhe der Teile nach links
Richtung Seitenlinie und wirst dort deinen zweiten
Punkt setzen.
Hier kannst du eine gerade Linie ziehen oder aber auch eine
ganz leichte Kurve.
Wenn du jetzt eine Kurve wählst, dann achte darauf,
dass sie im Bereich der Körpermitte relativ flach ist,
auch wie bei der Schnittkonstruktion,
dass also ein Winkel von 90 Grad bei der
Körpermitte entsteht.
Denn wir wollen ja diese Zeichnung später kopieren und
spiegeln und die andere Seite soll dann eben auch ganz
gerade weitergehen.
Wenn ich jetzt meinen Punkt an der Seitenlinie platziere,
platziere ich den nicht genau auf dem Körper.
Denn vielleicht könnt ihr euch erinnern in der Einführung
technische Modezeichnung.
Was ist das?
Es ist keine Modeillustration,
es ist eine technische Zeichnung,
die wirklich flach dargestellt wird.
Also setzt du diesen Punkt ein wenig außerhalb von der
Körperseite.
So, jetzt klickst du hier drauf und hältst entweder
geklickt, wenn du jetzt eine Kurve machen möchtest oder für
eine gerade Linie setzt du einfach den Punkt.
Dann gehst du nach unten.
Wir sind jetzt bei der Seite unseres Rockes und hier würde
ich dir empfehlen, jeden Fall eine Kurve zu zeichnen.
Die ist jetzt im oberen Bereich vor allem etwas gesprungen
und unten hin achtest du darauf,
dass die Linie relativ gerade ist.
Und dann setzt du hier unten am Saum deinen nächsten
Punkt.
Du könntest das jetzt auch mit zwei Punkten machen,
aber ich versuche im Illustrator immer
so wenig Punkte wie möglich zu benutzen,
um dann später die Zeichnung leichter transformieren
zu können.
Also setzt du jetzt deinen nächsten Punkt unten am Saum
und gehst dann wieder zurück zur Körpermitte.
Hier kannst du eine gerade Linie setzen,
könntest aber auch alternativ wenn du möchtest,
und die Zeichnung wirklich ganz besonders schön aussehen
soll, auch eine Kurve zeichnen.
Achte aber wieder darauf,
dass diese Kurve bei der Körpermitte wieder recht flach ist.
Und jetzt zeichnest du von der unteren Körpermitte
zurück zum Startpunkt zur oberen Körpermitte und
diese Linie muss ganz gerade sein.
Jetzt siehst du diesen kleinen Kreis und das heißt meine
Form wird geschlossen.
Das ist ganz wichtig,
schließ deine Form und schon hast du die erste Rockhälfte
gezeichnet.
Wir wollen diesen Rock nun kopieren und dann
spiegeln, aber bevor wir das tun,
schauen wir dass wir auch wirklich alles haben,
was wir benötigen, um diesen Rock zu spiegeln.
Denn wenn wir jetzt noch ein paar Details haben,
wäre es ganz günstig, wenn wir die auch gleich mitspiegeln
und dann nicht im Nachhinein nochmal doppelt zeichnen
müssen.
In unserem Modellrock haben wir eine Tasche und wir haben
Abnäher.
Diese werde ich jetzt erstmal noch einzeichnen,
bevor ich das Ganze spiegle.
Jetzt zeichne ich die Details ein.
In unserem Modellrock sind das die Taschen und die Abnäher
und bei meiner technischen Zeichnung variiert die Anzahl der
Abnäher vorne und hinten jetzt etwas im Vergleich zu unserem
Modellrock aus den Korsenschnittkonstruktionen und
Trappieren.
Die Anzahl kann einfach von Rock zu Rock
ganz unterschiedlich sein.
Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel zwei Abnäher,
vorne je Seite und einen hinten und bei unserem Modellrock
aus den Konstruktionskursen sind das ein Abnäher vorne und
zwei hinten.
Vielleicht kannst du dich erinnern als wir unser Format
angelegt haben, haben wir das Linienwerkzeug benutzt.
Das kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch nutzen und hier meine
Tasche einzeichnen.
Alternativ geht es natürlich auch mit dem
Zeichenstiftwerkzeug.
Mein Abnäher kann ich jetzt auch mit der Linie zeichnen oder
aber auch mit der Zeichenfeder.
Wenn ich vielleicht auch einen etwas größeren Abnäher habe,
dann lohnt es sich diesen auch ein wenig zu formen.
Ich unterscheide in der technischen Modezeichnung zwischen
der Konturlinie und den Details.
Der Abnäher und die Tasche sind Details und deswegen möchte
ich diese etwas weniger stark darstellen.
Dazu gehe ich in den Bedienfeld auf Kontur und stelle jetzt
hier über diese Pfeile einen geringeren Kontur ein.
Zum Beispiel 0,5 Punkt.
Der Kontur von meinem Rock an sich ist ein Punkt und 0,5
ist dann etwas dünner und das erscheint dann schon etwas
harmonischer.
Achte aber darauf, zu sehr runterzugehen.
Also bei 0,25 Punkt ist es zum Beispiel so, dass man,
wenn man diese Zeichnung dann drucken möchte,
oftmals diese Linien gar nicht mehr sieht, die dann
so fein gezeichnet sind.
Deswegen würde ich empfehlen Minimum 0,5 Punkt